- I love that with the belts.
We both have this kind of
western chic thing going on.
- I did this for you.
- [Kelly] I totally called her
and you wear your western chic.
(Gina laughs)
So where's the most exciting
place that you've been,
like you've traveled to, though?
- I've been to quite a
few places, thank God.
I've been blessed with that.
But I have to say Dubai.
- I've never been to Dubai.
- It was insane.
- [Kelly] Have you been to Dubai?
- Only at night, I flew in at night
and kind of was waiting for a connection.
I never really saw the city.
- [Kelly] Okay, that does not count.
- It was dark, it was nighttime.
It looked pretty good to me.
- That does not count.
- Dubai is one of those cities
that rose up out of nothing.
Somebody thought it
would be a good idea to
make this huge metropolitan oasis
with the most improbable architecture.
- I wanna go, everybody says this,
it's the most interesting place.
- Yeah, it really is.
- Yeah, and it does feel
like it's almost, like,
in a different year or time.
- It's a different time,
it's a different planet.
Sometimes, you get out into
the desert and there we are.
There's me and my honey
jumping from a sand dune.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
See now this is my thing with sand.
I don't do sand.
You just find it, it's like glitter.
It's like you find it for days.
- A week later.
- In every crack.
- Yeah, yeah, but it's Dubai sand.
- You know what?
I've never tried Dubai sand.
- Try Dubai sand, it could be different.
- It sounds like an ad.
- Exactly.
- Try Dubai sand.
- Your teenage daughter posted this TikTok
where she dressed you in her clothes.
- [Gina] Yep.
- [Kelly] First of all, you look fabulous.
- [Gina] That challenge.
- [Kelly] That looks like you would just
wear that on a Tuesday, you're so cute.
(Gina laughs)
You do not have a normal mom body.
Whose idea was that to do that?
- Oh, that was hers.
- [Kelly] Oh, hers, okay.
- Oh yeah, that was absolutely
a hundred percent Delilah.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yes and I was happy to do it
because if anybody out
there has a teenager
or has lived through having a teenager
then you know they're elusive
and if they want ya
they wanna spend time with you,
you actually, you absolutely
grab ahold of that time.
Yeah, so I was happy to do it.
Made me feel special and worthy.
- Oh, I'm a little scared,
my daughter's eight.
She still likes me and wants to do things.
- Yes, yeah, there's a
lot of sweetness still.
There's a lot of sweetness in there.
Bank it, bank it.
Put pictures of them
and their chubby cheeks
like when they're young, like
at hand, like keep 'em handy
'cause you'll need it.
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- It's good currency.
- Yeah, she's so independent.
She's gonna want nothing to do with me.
Please tell me that Dan
has styled you before.
And for TikTok, please.
- No, not for TikTok.
- Not for TikTok?
- [Eugene] He did style
me once a few years ago
for some opening.
A premier, you know, one of those things.
And he did dress me, but you know,
I was going out,
I was going outta town,
I was waiting for the car
to take me to the airport
and I, you know, I used
to put on a shirt and tie
and jacket, you know,
jeans, that kind of thing.
I was into that.
He walks out one day, he was four,
and he looks at me standing,
waiting for the car
and now he's looking at me and I said,
"What is it Daniel?"
He said,
"From here up, great."
(Gina laughs)
"From here down, gross."
(audience laughs)
- Gross!
- I said, you don't like
the jeans with the thing?
He was four.
And he has the greatest
sense of style now.
- [Kelly] He does, he does.
- Yes he's a fashion icon.
- Amazing.
- My six and eight year old will call-
literally we're going to dinner,
my friend is in the building
hearing this right now.
And we are about ready to go
and my son looked at me, he's six.
And he looked at me and he goes
"So are you gonna go get ready?"
(audience laughs)
- Oh!
- [Kelly] I was like
sorry, but I look really cute right now.
I was like, what?
I was like, I looked really
cute, Nirvana grunge.
I thought I was pulling it off.
And like, I'd literally
come straight from work
and then my daughter
comes around the corner
and not kidding, didn't
even hear Remy say it.
And River comes around
the corner and she's like
"Where are you going like that?"
And I was like, what the
heck is wrong with me?
(audience laughs)
My friends were there.
I went just like that, I'll have you know.
- [Gina] Good.
- You did not bully me into changing.
- Yes, they're brutal.
- [Kelly] I'm gonna hold onto it though,
at least they're looking
at me, paying attention.
Let's talk about 9-1-1: Lone Star.
So you play a paramedic captain?
- [Gina] Yes.
- So did you have to do training for that?
- No, not necessarily.
- [Kelly] Okay, how do you look
like you're doing it right?
- Well, thank you.
- [Kelly] Okay yeah, how do you do that?
How do you do that?
- We have an amazing med tech on the set
at all times that takes us
through all the procedures
and, you know, the rescue of the day.
- That's cool.
- [Gina] But when I started,
I mean, they were already, you know
they were already rolling on the tracks.
I came in season two,
so they didn't have a whole
lot of time to catch me up.
But they did bring me into this giant room
with like, two banquet tables
and they were full of all
the kind of instruments
and equipment and like splints and stuff.
- Forceps and all those
things, all those things.
- You can see, right? You can see
the extensive training
that I've gone through
to be a paramedic.
- Don't wanna get too technical.
- Yes, I don't wanna intimidate
you with my knowledge
of what I'm doing.
(audience laughs)
But I'm such a teacher's pet
that all I wanna do is make her happy.
And she loves me because
I retain all that stuff.
- Oh see, I don't retain well.
- So I can retain it, I'm
like okay, this is what it is
and then there's like, the medical jargon
which is a whole other thing
and then you have to
like, be in the moment
and it's all happening so fast.
But she loves me because
I just wanna please her.
And I retain it and I'm
able to get in there
and make it look convincing enough.
- [Kelly] You do a great job of that.
- Thank you.
- So what can you tell us
about this new season, though?
- It's fabulous.
(audience claps)
Yeah, right, good, thank you.
Thank you, fans of the show.
Last season we started
off with a big freeze.
This season it's another weather event
but it's the opposite; it is heat.
It is another weather phenomenon.
And we have great guests,
we have epic saves and rescues
and maybe a little romance.
- Oh, I like it.
- Little romance, yes,
yes, with Tommy Vega
so that's good, coming out of
her shell a little bit more
so that's always fun to play.
- [Kelly] I love that, alright.